the beliefs that we have really control
our actions we don't typically go at
things or do things that we believe
we're not good at so I'm gonna share
with you how to get rid of your limiting
beliefs right now I'm moving beyond your
limiting beliefs is a critical step
toward becoming happier and more
successful rise and shine it since preso
time goodmorning belief nation
my name is lily and my one word is
extraordinary i believe that every
single human being is capable of
extraordinary things when they embrace
who they truly are so let's start the
day off right together grab me a cup of
coffee and step on today's message get
rid of your limiting beliefs over to you
Jordan Belfour beliefs essentially the
beliefs that you hold about yourself
about your capabilities about money
whether your beliefs that attract money
to you or that repel money whether that
you have beliefs that allow you to move
through barriers and obstacles or
beliefs that cause you to shy away from
Batteries and obstacles and the beliefs
that we have really control our actions
we don't typically go at things or do
things that we believe we're not good at
we don't take actions everything we're
gonna fail we shy away and then of
course we don't say that we're scared we
come up with a story
so the sort of these negative these
limiting beliefs Institute it's the gate
that's telling the bull stories to
ourselves right and it holds us back
from success so the idea is that is to
understand what your core limiting
beliefs are and then to actually break
those beliefs and you can do that's not
that difficult to do it do it in a
seminar setting you break the limiting
beliefs and you essentially empower
somebody by helping them install their
own beliefs in themselves most your
beliefs are malleable you can change
them so the idea is to essentially
retrofit your beliefs to serve you and
your outcomes in the case of
entrepreneurs stuff and money is not the
root of all evil that building the
business is possible that I
and Lerman every novel sort of leaks
right if you want an extraordinary
quality of life that you need to get rid
of your limiting beliefs limiting
beliefs are these false stories that we
make up in our heads that we've believed
to be true there was a time in my life
that I allowed my limiting beliefs to
run my life it cost me my relationship
it cost me to silence myself constantly
and it almost cost me my life there was
a time that I believed that this life
was not worth living because my inner
world was not reflecting my external
world I had so much inside of me to
share and I let my limiting beliefs get
in the way it wasn't until I lost
someone really close to me that really
jerked me into reality and tell me that
I needed to get rid of all of those
limiting beliefs and I saw how my life
expanded since then and I don't want
that for you
I don't want that for you at all so I'm
gonna share with you how to get rid of
your limiting beliefs right now so
you're gonna grab a piece of paper and
make three columns the first column is
going to be your core limiting beliefs
you need to be honest with yourself what
are they
column number two is going to be what is
it costing you and column number three
is the truth is so I'm gonna use myself
as an example my core limiting beliefs
were I'm not enough I'm not worthy I
need to stay small and ordinary and what
it cost me was my quality of life my
relationships and most importantly
building a tribe of people who want to
change the world the truth is my words
and actions will inspire people to
change the world and that's what you
need to do you need to get rid of those
limiting beliefs and embrace your truth
what is your truth and once you embrace
that then you could have the
extraordinary quality of life that I was
talking about earlier you could have
everything you want everything that you
dream of but the first thing you need to
do is get rid of
now I got a special bonus clip for you
but before we get to that the question
of the day is what is your limiting
belief and beside it write down what
your truth is leave it in the comments
below and I'll join in on the discussion
now thank you guys so much for watching
I believe in you and I hope you continue
to believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is and we'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso now enjoy the bonus clip get
rid of your limiting beliefs
oh my gosh I get so well in the back
room what is going on okay
[Music]
make fun of Lilly day today
[Music]
mistake you might unknowingly be making
and therefore sabotaging your
unhappiness with is allowing yourself to
be controlled by your limiting beliefs
many of us have beliefs that limit our
success whether their beliefs about our
own capabilities beliefs about what it
takes to succeed or even beliefs about
how we should relate to other people now
moving beyond your limiting beliefs is a
critical step toward becoming happier
and more successful and then do this you
must first believe that you're capable
of accomplishing your goals and you're
capable of being happy and here's a
simple but powerful four-step process
you can use to transform any limiting
belief into an empowering belief the
first step is identify a limiting belief
that you want to change the second step
is to determine how that belief is
limiting you now
the third step is to decide how you
would rather be after feel and the
fourth step is to create a turnaround
statement that affirms or gives you
permission to be to act or to feel this
new way for example a negative belief
might be if I express my true feelings
people will think I'm weak and take
advantage of me
now the turnaround belief would be the
more I express my true feelings the more
people love respect admire and support
me now once you've created a new belief
you will need to implant it into your
subconscious mind through constant
repetition for 2 or 3 minutes several
times a day for a minimum of 30 days I'm
a storyteller and I I'm not someone who
restricts myself to one thing ever I've
never been that person maybe I have EDD
but I want to be able to do everything
why can't we do everything sure you know
as an especially women we are mark we're
great at multitasking so I want to
produce I want to have a business I'm
gonna I'm producing here I'm gonna
produce in India Hindi films regional
films
I want to be able to act in them maybe
not you know there's so many things that
I can do which I want to be able to
explore working with my friend in this
yeah
he's incredible he was the first player
I ever did or acting police was much ado
about nothing which now we all studied
his film over and over again and now
sort of you come full circle and work
with Nelly's was incredible I can to one
of the people I've never been challenged
so much with some changing things you
know doing it different okay we've got
that now try this and and it really gets
you out of that sort of you know bad
habit of saying oh no my character only
does this I think that you know when you
limp yourself like that you limit
possibilities and Kim was all about
experimenting in just gallon for taking
that risk and work sometimes sometimes
it doesn't and you know that's part of
the journey raise your standard Apple at
the core its core value is that we
believe that people with passion can not
one drop of my self-worth depends on
your it's supposed to mean I don't ever
give up I'd have to be dead or
completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details